des scientifiques de l'année de radio
canada à partir de là comme le plus
rapidement possible dont l'appétit
l'amour dit courbe l'on veuille donner
un grand coup regardez hypothèse les
scénarios pu évidemment on va regarder
la courbe pour pas qu'elle vienne nous
remettre dans une montée exponentielle
si on continue comme ça on va rentrer
dans le mur croissance exponentielle
modèle projection on n'a jamais autant
parlé de mathématiques que depuis le
début de cette pandémie
au fil des points de presse des
autorités les courbes nous ont permis de
mesurer l'ampleur de la menace et
l'impact de nos actions individuelles et
collectives sur la propagation du virus
derrière ces scénarios il y a des
dizaines de modélisateurs dont les
calculs alimente depuis un an les
décisions des autorités sanitaires
[Musique]
c'est un défi colossal qui a mobilisé la
discipline prévoir l'évolution de la
pandémie grâce là des modèles
mathématiques féliciter pour récompenser
cet immense effort collectif
radio canada remet son prix de
scientifique de l'année à quatre d'entre
eux julien arino de l'université du
manitoba
marc brisson de l'université laval
caroline colline de l'université simon
fraser en colombie-britannique et
mathieu mahut giroud de l'université
mcgill il travaillait jusqu'ici sur le
vih la tuberculose le virus du papillome
humain 2020 leur a apporté un défi
inattendu transposer dans des modèles la
transmission d'aquavit 19 dans la
population
la modélisation permet de traduire des
concepts en langage mathématique lui
puis comprendre un peu qu'est ce qui se
produit par exemple avec une épidémie où
se trouve la transmission qui sont les
gens qui acquiert etc
c'est sûr que c'est une approximation
mais ça permet de faire une bonne
approximation des caractéristiques
principales du système dans la version
la plus simple de ces modèles appli sfr
chaque individu est soit susceptible
d'être infecté ici en jambes soient
infectieux en rouge ou rétablies en
verre traduite en équation mathématique
les interactions entre ces catégories
donne les fameuse courbe devant un
nouveau virus
tout le monde est à priori susceptible
et les infections vont croître jusqu'à
atteindre sommet puis décroître au fur
et à mesure que les malades se
rétablissent et ne peuvent en principe
plus être infecté apprendre comment
encore faut-il connaître la maladie à
laquelle on a affaire au début d'une
maladie émergente comme comcom l'aco
vide
donc c'est ce qu'on appelle une maladie
émergente on n'a pas de connaissances
pratiques
les différentes caractéristiques de la
maladie de la maladie à combien de
personnes 1 individu infecté risque-t-il
de transmettre le virus
combien de temps reste t contagieux qui
sont les gens les plus susceptibles au
fil des mois
les réponses à ces questions se sont
précisées au sujet du nouveau
coronavirus qu'au début on avait très
peu d'informations sur la biologie ou
sur le virus sa sévérité
donc la quantité d'informations à
évoluer la quantité d'informations aussi
qu'on a sur les données de code
totalisation le raffinement de ces
données là nous permet d'avoir des
modèles plus raffinés dès le mois de
février
l'équipe de caroline collin se base par
exemple sur des données rapportées en
chine et à singapour pour montrer que
les gens infectés peuvent devenir
contagieux jusqu'à trois jours avant
d'avoir des symptômes
c'est le genre d'informations qui
permettront d'améliorer les modèles et
leurs prédictions et rendront d'autant
plus crucial certaines mesures mises en
place par les autorités
nous fermerons nos frontières aux gens
qui ne sont pas citoyens ou résidents
permanents du canada à winnipeg en
collaboration avec l'agencé de santé
publique du canada
julien arino s'intéresse aux risques
d'importation du virus ou ping en
intégrant à son modèle de transmission
de la maladie des données de déplacement
ils tentent de déterminer d'où pourrait
arriver la menace même si vous avez déjà
des cas à ce moment-là savoir comment
d'autres pays avec lesquels vous êtes en
relation quel est le risque que court
et est aussi importante puisque il y
avait au début quand même encore pas mal
de voyages
entre pays et donc savoir quel est l
état d autres pays étaient était
important en mars
l'épidémie prend de la vigueur en
particulier au québec c'est pour ça
qu'on demande à compter d'aujourd'hui de
fermer les lieux où les personnes se
rassemblent à l'université laval marc
brisson propose son aide à la santé
publique
quand j'ai commencé à mobiliser il m'a
calmé je me suis rendu compte que les
seules interventions qu'on est là à voir
au début parce qu'on avait pas de vaccin
pas nécessairement des traitements
steiss des mesures comportementale j'ai
remarqué qu'on n'avait pas aussi donné
là au québec et ailleurs au canada son
équipe relance alors une étude entamée
en 2018 sont les contacts sociaux des
québécois des données cruciales pour
évaluer l'impact des mesures sanitaires
qui seront mis en place au cours des
mois suivants notre but premier c'est
toujours de faire des scénarios
donc ce n'était pas de faire de la
projection de qu'est ce qui va se passer
dans les prochaines semaines c'est
plutôt de dire mais si mes contacts
diminue
voici ce qu on prévoir voici la tendance
pour espacer be si les contacts humains
mais voici ce qui se pourrait se passe
l'effet des mesures de confinement est
flagrant de 7 à 8 contact significatifs
par jour avant la pandémie
les québécois n'en avait plus que trois
en moyenne au printemps
mais pendant l'été et surtout à
l'automne des contacts repartent à la
hausse
la contamination il aidé c'est aussi ce
qu'on voit pour l'instant une
augmentation importante des corps si on
continue comme ça on va dépasser notre
capacité partout au pays
l'épidémie reprend de la vigueur dans
les points de presse des autorités
les projections des modélisateurs font
figure d'avertissement
nous nous attendons à vingt mille cas
diagnostiqués par jour d'ici la fin de
décembre
je pense que c'est très utile d'avoir
une manière ou une façon de communiquer
avec le public parce que les actions et
les choix dans le public quand la
communauté général général saas etc ou
le contrôle de lakovic 19 se placent sur
ses pages juste les décisions des
autorités c'est tout le monde c'est nous
tous en collaboration avec l'institut
national d'excellence en santé et
services sociaux
mathieu giroux et son équipe euh racines
leur modèle de projection des besoins
hospitaliers
l'objectif c'est de savoir sur une
échelle en cours et celle de peut-être
trois quatre semaines combien de lits
vont être occupés par des patients avec
un diagnostic de l'aco vite donc la
façon que le travail se fait c'est en
utilisant un modèle mathématique qui est
calibré ou données passées
d'hospitalisation on estime à un taux de
transmission à partir de toits pour la
dernière période et on projette ce taux
pour les trois quatre prochaines
semaines les projections sont refaites
chaque semaine un travail éreintant pour
les chercheurs la pression est forte
les questions sont nombreuses et les
gouvernements comme le public espère des
réponses bien des questions que l'on se
pose et puis je ne peux tu faire
explique exemple on essaie de donner la
meilleure réponse qu'on peut on est déçu
par cours avec des souvent de
l'information que qui était limitée qui
était partiel qui était biaisé pis on
devait être par le muc on pouvait aller
puis c'est ce que j'ai trouvé un peu
difficile c'est toujours du ce de bien
transmettre des résultats de
mobilisation on a toujours un souci de
faire peur aux à la roja de présenter
les données scientifiques d'une façon
compréhensible mais de donner l'heure
juste
la pandémie a propulsé la modélisation
des maladies infectieuses sur le devant
de la scène il y a de plus en plus de
modélisateurs mathématiques en
épidémiologie houérou informatique en
fait les gens qui font de la
modélisation vraiment cette crise a
montré qu effectivement les
mathématiques avait quelque chose à
contribuer eux aussi dans ce domaine
donc c'est le pense que c'est important
un petit velours pour nos lauréats il
l'occasion à saisir car nous avons
proposé deux réseaux de modélisateurs
achiou qui veut travailler avec les
épidémiologistes la santé publique cours
augmenter et améliorer ses problèmes
avec la capacité au canada de
démobilisation mais le marathon de la
pandémie n'est pas terminée pour les
chercheurs quand sa femme dans une
deuxième vague le peu de premières
vagues
c'est de la petite bière par rapport à
la 12e il faut prévoir entre autres les
faits de la vaccination sont les courbes
de l'épidémie une étape qu'ils espèrent
moins ardue
c'est très dur à prévoir commun et on va
réagir à telle ou telle mesure parce
qu'un vaccin si on a tout les paramètres
du vaccin mais c'est plus facile à
intégrer une fonction intégrée qui on le
sait ce constat je vous dirais que les
cas critiques du vaccin qui suit plus
facile à modéliser que les comportements
humains
la pente a été raide les il ya de
l'espoir au bout de la courbe
[Musique]